back in october of 2020 a woman named
sarah melger brought her then one month
old baby to the hospital reporting that
the child suffered from a number of
serious health problems she said that he
wouldn't eat and he was constantly
vomiting she had told the child's father
that he had a fever of 102.5
which is a dangerous temperature for a
child that age
she said that he had heart defects she
told other family members that the baby
suffered from hearing problems as well
as
down syndrome twice over the course of
two months the hospital performed spinal
taps on the baby inserting a needle in
between two vertebrae to test him for
sepsis
a couple of months later she was back at
the hospital frantically claiming that
the child wouldn't eat and he was
dehydrated so a feeding tube was
inserted
over time the stories about the child's
medical problems became increasingly
dramatic
and disturbing
and also fictional there was no sepsis
there was no fever there was no vomiting
or hearing problems or eating problems
the child didn't have down syndrome
sarah melger had made all of that up it
was munchausen by proxy a disorder where
a caretaker almost always a mother
pretends that a child is sick and she
does this for attention or for sympathy
maybe because she derives some sort of
sick satisfaction from watching her
child suffer perhaps it's a combination
of these things whatever her twisted
reasons melger was eventually arrested
and charged and finally this summer
convicted
of three counts of injury to a child
now her sentence community supervision
was outrageously lenient
but at least she won't be able to
contact her child who certainly is
better off now never seeing his deranged
abusive mother
ever again
but munchausen takes other more
pervasive and even more disturbing forms
worst of all these other forms that it
takes are perfectly legal
by the standards of our laws today
more than legal actually they're
celebrated
they may even result in a modeling
contract
so this month a ten-year-old boy named
noella mcmahor
has been making headlines as the
youngest quote trans model in the
country now of course it would be creepy
and inappropriate to put a ten-year-old
on the runway no matter what you know
whether
whether whether it's a boy or a girl
and most everyone agrees in most
situations
that it's creepy and inappropriate as
things like you know child beauty
pageants have finally fallen out of
favor in recent years and rightfully so
but exceptions are made for cases like
this boy because he allegedly does not
identify as a boy
you know in our culture it is wildly
offensive to dress little girls up in
lots of makeup and parade them around
and it should be seen as offensive but
it's beautiful and brave to do the exact
same thing to a little boy
outlets like out magazine have been
raving about noella reading now from uh
their article says ten-year-old noella
mcmahor is already making her dreams
come true six years after she began
transitioning
six years
okay the child is 10.
noella has made history as the youngest
out trans model ever to walk a runway
during new york fashion week when she
walked from designer mel atkinson and
trans clothing company walked for them
rather noella doesn't ever get nervous
or scared by anything she's a tiny
professional nuella's mother dee mcmaher
told metro uk she was so excited to go
down the catwalk excited to see all the
people and the cameras she knows exactly
how to work a crowd
we are so proud of noella for being the
first trans child in new york fashion
week where in all of her confidence and
determination she continued noella
already has so many transgender people
of all ages contact her for advice and
support
a ten-year-old is being asked for advice
and support
indeed people of all ages adults even
apparently are consulting this
prepubescent child for advice
now i suppose it's no surprise that a
mother would put her child in the
position of providing guidance to adults
given that she's already put him in the
position of being a runway model
speaking of the mother the glowing media
profiles
seem oddly reluctant to tell us much
about the child's home life
they tell us a little bit
some of the basics
but what exactly is going on at home
and when you investigate the subject you
immediately understand why they're so
hesitant
the website redux has a report today
revealing some of the rather dark
details
about what noella is dealing with at
home
here's what they report at age four
noella was socially transitioned it was
around this time that noella's mother
said that uh she brought the child to
therapy at the gender development clinic
at ann and robert h laurie children's
hospital chicago
during the appointments noella told a
gender counselor that he was a girl by
age six noella's legal documentation had
already been changed d mcmahor noella's
biological mother is a social justice
advocate who identifies as non-binary
appears to be on hormone replacement
therapy and recently had a cosmetic
mastectomy both she and her current
partner are females who identify as
trans masculine
according to the point foundation
website mcmahon has been an advocate and
educator for transgender children for 10
years roughly since around the time
noella was born
in 2019 mcmahon noella were featured in
people's world during a legal episode in
which mcmahon was fighting for full
custody of her child from her biological
father uh timothy mccord
or from his biological father right
the report goes on to reveal that mccord
the father did not agree uh with his
son's transition didn't agree that his
son was transgender he opposed the
transition but he lost the ability to
prevent it in 2016 after mcmahon claimed
that the father fractured the boy's arm
while trying to force him into quote boy
pajamas
mccord was arrested for child abuse
mcnair also pressed to have him charged
with an anti-trans hate crime the hate
crime charge never materialized but
mccord did plead down to a lesser charge
and was given probation
meanwhile mcmahon the mother
married a female named ray
who also identifies as trans and works
in the field of quote lgbtq health
justice
now in 2019 noella mccord was profiled
by the website chicago parent under the
headline
seven-year-old stands up for transgender
rights
in the article the mother brags about
her trans child
claiming that she transitioned him as a
toddler so that he could feel safe and
be happy
and she says that her son is brave and
fierce and a force to be reckoned with
these are all descriptions that don't
describe
any seven-year-old i've ever met because
seven-year-olds are small children they
are not forces to be reckoned with
but that's how the mother sees the child
he is not a child at all but a political
and ideological cudgel to be wielded
he's a mascot to be paraded around
he's an accessory a fashion statement
he's also a thing to be experimented on
and on that note
the chicago parent article contains this
passage
quote
dee is looking forward to watching ella
continue to grow and turn into the
person she is and was meant to be in the
next few years she will start puberty
blockers and hormones and begin the
physical transition process with gender
surgeries at 16.
so they've already decided
for him that he's going to get the drugs
in the surgery
they decided this while the child was
still in diapers
they shoved him down this path and cut
off all the exits by publicly declaring
his gender identity to the world and
putting him in the position of being an
inspiration and a force
you know and a source of wisdom and
guidance for the whole lgbt community
you can't change his mind now
of course he can't because he never made
up his mind to begin with this isn't his
mind choosing any of this it's his
mother
manipulating and controlling him
it is exactly like sarah melger
in that case right down to the
unnecessary medical procedures
the only difference is that the typical
munchausen mommy
is out for attention and sympathy mainly
and there's an element of that here as
well certainly d mcmahor wants attention
no question about that
but she's also looking to her child for
something else
that i think is a little bit of a twist
from the average uh munchausen case
she's looking for affirmation
so it is actually not a misnomer to say
that when a parent trans is a child
she is engaging in the process of
affirmation it's actually true
it is affirmation
but it's affirmation of
herself not her child the child like
doesn't even exist her child has no face
no identity
he's a canvas a blank screen that his
mother projects her fantasies and
delusions onto
nobody exists
but to affirm her
this is especially true of her child
she makes her child sick
so that she can feel
well and rather than handcuffs and
criminal charges
all she gets in response is
applause
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast